Common birds, like
the pigeon shown here,
exhibit grace and
precision in flight
that far exceeds our best
robotic capabilities.
Inspired by these
maneuvers, we have
built an autonomous
aircraft capable of fast,
accurate, and repeatable flight.
Utilizing motion capture
for feedback control,
we demonstrate this
system by flying
through a gap that is smaller
than the aircraft's wingspan.
Accurate control in
these flight regimes
is difficult because of
the complex airflow induced
at high angles of attack.
We capture 120 frames per
second onboard video for use
in studying machine vision.
Here, we demonstrate avoiding
vertical and horizontal
obstacles.
Finally, we show these
videos in real-time.
[WHIRRING]